oh say it isn't so
it appears that derek hough is injured
according to Instagram pics posted by
both Derek and Mark Ballas the Dancing
with the Stars Pro spent the night in
the emergency room following Monday's
Spring Break themed episode of the show
Valis sharing this photo of a sad faced
derek with the caption long night in the
ER with derek hough nothing worse than
seeing a fellow dancer get hurt
especially your brother Derek's
Instagram post which he deleted showed
he may have injuries to both feet he
wrote just getting home from the
hospital not the best news I'm in utter
disbelief it's unclear exactly how
Derek's sustained the injuries in fact
he told ET backstage that he's been
keeping in tip-top shape
I've personally been taking care of
myself so much more than I used to and
I'm getting like a cardio workout
everyday doing the shows so I actually
feel more in shape than I normally do
this kind besides performing on Dancing
with the Stars with gymnast Nastia
Liukin the pro dancer is also the male
lead in the new york spring spectacular
at Radio City Music Hall alongside the
Rockette et has reached out to Huff's
rep but no word yet on how his injuries
will affect his current gigs wishing
Derek a speedy recovery